hallo wo vor der vox startet ich finds
richtig auf die zukunft also dieser
diese szene ist jetzt komplett live
gedreht wir haben mit gerade sonntag in
zwölfter mai also den muttertag in
diesem sinne einen schönen muttertag in
allem mütter und ich wollte euch nur
noch ganz kurz darauf hinweisen wie vor
in den block schaut dieser block wurde
vier bis fünf tage vor ramadan begonnen
und natürlich haben wir im block war ja
auch kein hammer natürlich haben wir da
auch mal mittags gegessen und dann sehen
wir ganz ganz viel essen im block und
möchte ich mich jetzt schon dafür
entschuldigen falls der hunger bekommt
auch wenn haben vorrang war dann gedreht
und dann bis zum ersten tag vom ramadan
und deswegen hat man halt noch gegessen
deshalb eine kleine warnung vorab mit
ganz viel spaß beim block
[Musik]
hier seien herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen blog von mir von hansa und wir
haben
ich lasse mich meinem blog aber ich habe
gedacht wir sind jetzt so ein paar tage
vor ramadan
da ist doch vielleicht ganz interessant
ich mal so ein bisschen mit zu dem ich
weiß nicht was euch erwartet wie lassen
sich ganz spontan noch uns zukommen so
wir drehen den snack irres knoblauchbrot
und wir haben sie muss sich erst mal
bereit machen hier also wir sind noch
nicht komplett eingezogen immer noch
nicht und drehen tun wir aber natürlich
schon so machst du dann mal hier und sie
in teamarbeit
du kannst du nicht in jogginghose drehen
[Musik]
nein die leute sehen ich zwar nicht aber
okay als gutes entschuldigt damit ist
das ist so eine große gefahr weil wir
noch keine möbel haben damit gekommen
ein bisschen schon wieder eingepackt
damit weniger schaden ist was ganz
großes
später haben sie wird zeige ich euch wie
immer fernseh gucken
so haben sie gerade so haben sie
verbringe ich würde sagen ich habe heute
den trockner gestern nachmittag den
nachbarn was man hat vielleicht das muss
auch schauen dass man schön erstehen
wo kaufen die geben sie in unserem shop
boys
dass du ein schock wir haben eine chance
egal wichtig nicht gleich an den
computer setzen und kaufen das sie gar
nicht für das kostet jetzt haben wir
unser video gedreht es ist gerade pause
bei den teig geht und jetzt koch ich
irgendwas hier habe ich dort besser
das hackfleisch das hatte ich letztens
in ein kino also wirklich ein kilo
komplett eingefroren und dann einen teil
davon
und dann muss ich es komplett braten
also ich musste das komplett braten und
dann muss ich es gebraten und nochmal
einfrieren hin und her habe ich jetzt
fertig gebracht eine fatale umgefüllt
und da habe ich jetzt eine kooperation
im schrank haben wir jetzt einfach
kidney bohnen und dann nehmen wir noch
ein bisschen schwieriger tomaten und
dann gucken wir was draus und das haben
wir gerade gefilmt ich hatte euch das
auf instagram schon gezeigt der mit
erfolg der weiß glaube ich jetzt was es
wird und zwar knoblauch brot mit käse
oder leute leute so lecker aber das muss
jetzt noch gehen noch zehn minuten ein
bisschen koche ich jetzt schnell was
[Musik]
die
für das protesten ofen und ich musste
jetzt stoppen ich habe jetzt hier noch
fettarme sahne reingetan eigentlich
werden passierte tomaten die bessere
wahl aber ich hatte leider kenne da ist
nicht schlimm
und hier habe ich hier harte nudeln
nudeln und es gebe ich die masse einfach
drauf es ist leckerer als es aussieht
sagen wir es mal so die farben sind
nicht sehr ansprechend aber es ist echt
lecker
eigentlich wollte ich jetzt eine schöne
zeit raus machen und so schöne aufnahme
habe das alles kaputt gemacht
das ist vollkommen sag mal ist das eine
belastung auch anbieter tatsache auf
welcher seite denn auch kiki scoach.de
doch wesentlich genial
ich glaube ich besuche mal die seite und
konnte meine mama damit sie mir schon
was kaufen kann ich meinen text mein
bruder wurde aber von seiner mutter früh
[Musik]
muss man doch diese lahcen dabei an
haben klappt das der trick sonst nicht
oder ist so und das knoblauchbrot was
wir haben sie jetzt gerade wo er noch
die entsehen macht und die fotos macht
das ist für den kauf für einen kanal das
kommt auf den kaufen und leihen und das
rezept habe ich ja mal ausprobiert vor
ein paar auf instagram hab ich's gezeigt
und ich wollte dem rezept haben und da
habe ich mir überlegt ob er cool darf
nämlich das akku zwar für den kanal
hätte ich für meinen kanal abgefilmt
weil das rezept exakt gleich geblieben
hätte sich nichts verändert hätte nur
die zutaten in durchsichtige schüssel
umgefüllt
also ihr seht die kaufen kooperation die
ist ganz einfach ich bin eine ganz
einfache leidenschaftlich
leidenschaftliche kaufen kunden die mit
kaufen kooperiert und ganz einfach für
diesen kanal rezepte entwickelt und ja
und ich würde mich natürlich auch sehr
freuen wenn ihr den kanal abonniert und
dort auf die glocke aktiviert dann
verpasst ihr nehmen von mitteln video
mehr und so ungefähr zweimal im monat
kommt da ein video von mir also ein
rezept vor mir und es ist jetzt keine
abgesprochene werbung dass ihr das auch
noch ist also generell hier dieser block
der ist ganz normal aus freien stücken
egal was ich zeige und ich muss
natürlich immer ich muss natürlich immer
schreiben unterstützt sich produktion
weil ihr seht ja ihr seht ihr immer
marke nirgendwo also man sieht immer
irgendwo eine marke
so das ist immer meine abendliche
routine
hier habe ich nicht angeregt das ist
sich noch sie teil der küche gegen
schüler sonst immer so zu sagen und das
hier ist eine alte matratze und was muss
ich gucken fußball champions
league-halbfinale ein neuer tag geht's
heute dem ich euch auch nochmal mit bh 4
13 uhr 30 werden und morgen einen termin
bei uns zuhause bezüglich der küche
müssen wir noch gemacht wir haben ein
bisschen an der homepage gearbeitet für
den online-shop feinheiten müssen sie
noch das video das haben übrigens
gestern gestern habe ich euch nicht
mitgenommen sondern vorgestern und
gestern natürlich nicht mit bei dieser
masse viel zu tun hat jetzt nicht so ich
sehe mich mehr um meine zeit nehme ich
mir als dect werden und wir haben ist
dann das hier gefilmt last berry
jetzt habe ich hier 100 euch nicht die
hälfte ist schon mit puderzucker die
andere vor der kamera machen und das ist
mir jetzt noch also fotografieren und
dienten fertig machen genau und dann
geht es später noch in den shop ein paar
pakete packen und danach noch zur
steuerberaterin verbringe ich hab ein
paar stücke
hatten ja viele pakete im moment ist
super freut und wieder so regel bestellt
um uns vertraut habe ich ja gesagt jetzt
einzelne produkt ist von mir auf herz
und nieren getestet und freue mich aber
sehr dass wir uns da vertraut und doch
machen wir alles selber und dass man sie
auf zeit wir können und unterstützt uns
noch der kann werde ich euch dann wenn
er sich traut auf dem blog vorstellen
restlichen lesen
[Musik]
jetzt fangen wir ein kurzvideo quasi
gedreht für diese partie pärchen das ist
unser erstes video für die ramadan reihe
die steuerberaterin hat ihren termin
verschoben es gar nicht schlimm ist was
uns aber auch richtig gut passen
das heißt wir gehen jetzt in den shop
und die ich dann mal wenn alles zeitlich
passt meine eltern besuchen was suchst
du deine schuhe wäre ja das ist so das
habe ich also das nennt man auch
schuhschrank
das nennt man auch mal schwach so ja der
schuhschrank ist schon aufgebaut worden
von uns sagen wir schon ganz fleißig nur
an die wand kameraden zu erinnern nicht
dran machen
da muss der papa herr baumann passt das
nicht hin hatte hatte ich habe schon
welche drin muss kurz an machen
und jetzt können wir abbauen
[Musik]
habe ich den einen tag nicht mitnehmen
können wir waren bis nachts im shop und
haben die ganzen pakete bearbeitet wenn
wir uns ist es auch so behandeln wie wir
können dann auch erst wirklich erwarten
entspannte sein okay sei alles erledigt
und wir wollten das unbedingt noch
erlebt haben
deswegen war es für meine eltern konnten
nicht mehr besuchen aus zeitmangel
aber heute ist ein neuer tag und wir
haben das neues in der küche das zeige
ich euch ma lin und zwar schaut mal hier
habe ich holzkästen und zwar sind die
dafür da also erst mal fürs optische das
bild noch mal ein bisschen wärme reihen
und sehr sehr praktisch denn man kann
hier jetzt köpfe kräutertöpfe oder zum
beispiel öl hin tun also isst im super
praktisch weil man halt immer mal ein
stopp irgendjemand muss man nicht immer
an die schränke auch machen zu machen
sondern hatte immer griffbereit genauso
wie mit den kräutern mal so papa sie die
komplette es unzählige möglichkeiten an
köpfen und ich freue mich richtig drauf
ich werde morgen mal einkaufen gehen und
das sind schöne füllen heute ist schon
ein bisschen zu spät wir haben heute ein
video gedreht
wir machen nicht herunter das ist
dagegen dass ich genau sagt das ist eine
punktation rohheit seinem
produktplatzierungen sie haben
wahrscheinlich an einem video das
bestimmt schon online wenn der blog
online geht
das ist jetzt gerade einfach immer dann
lockt ein fahrer vor ramadan blog also
es geht ja also es ist noch da also wann
ist noch zwei tage
hier kocht gerade meine hähnchenbrust
vor sich hin mit salz pfeffer und sieben
gewürz das separate hat das ist richtig
richtig lecker zu hähnchen und der topf
ist noch leer
und jetzt machen wir zusammen
[Musik]
während mainburgs vor sich hin guard
wollte ich euch nun ganz kleinen tricks
zeigen und zwar gibt es hier diese
paprika und tomaten bank auch in diesem
großen gläsern ich bin ja jetzt mal nur
zu zweit mit haben sich koch zwar viel
aber ich brauche immer ganz lange bis
sich das auf brauche und mache ich das
mal so gibt ja immer gutes
kaltgepresstes olivenöl ganz einfach auf
die oberfläche wenn ich das jetzt
verschließt und dem kühlschrank holen
dann kann da auch nichts mehr schimmeln
wichtig ist nur dass die oberfläche
einer komplett abgedeckt
so und jetzt weil mich die küche auch
und ihr könnt mir dabei zu sehen
[Musik]
wie entspannt das immer aussieht wenn
man im zeitraffer aufräume denken
dieser tritt fertig aber in beiden
ländern das sind was die aufnahme gern
zu sagen so jetzt ist mein essen fertig
und ich mache nur noch den joghurt und
dann essen sich gerade zwei zähler zum
anrichten und das ist so traurig müsste
ich mal meine teller schublade angucken
was ich hier für teller
das sind meine teller
ich habe glaube ich keine zwei gleichen
wir haben sie nicht essen dann ist zb
auch mit dem einer von dem teller
das ding ist wie haben wir gesagt kaufst
dir keinen reset voll deiner hochzeit
glauben ja du willst welche geschenkt
bekommen das ist ja so also für aber
dass er so wenn man geheiratet hat dann
hat man immer alles für die wohnung
geschenkt bekommen dann hatte man die
drei wasserkocher und toaster und so ich
bin sehr gut dass es nicht mehr so ist
aber ich habe echt gewesen
das erscheint wenn ich mich holen würde
und vielleicht kommt dann doch jemand
auf die idee und dann kam nicht muss ich
dringend dringend geschehen holen für
den alltag das ist nicht mein fotografie
geschehen also alles unterschiedliche
teller im monopoly einfach nur für die
fotos so wir haben sie habe ich hier den
mount everest und jetzt mein teller und
der burg uhse ist so saftig also ich hab
jetzt keine weise dazu gemacht teppichen
überlegt ob ich eine machen soll aber
eigentlich gar nicht zusammen mit dem
joghurt eigentlich perfekt und dann kann
man sich das sparen was ist passiert
alles wieder gut sind nur ein paar
stunden vergangen meine eltern kamen und
das war's auch danach war ich im shop
und ich bin total heiß weil ich habe
meine abend stimme eingelegt sie ist
nämlich 31 78 und ich habe jetzt morgen
auf zürich keine lust mehr
guten morgen geboren sind unterwegs und
der hamas ließ auch dabei ist es oft
frühstück unterwegs mit brot und käse
größte stunde
jetzt wundert ihr euch war ja küche das
auch passt auch wenn ich hier haben ja
immer das problem dass für togo einfach
keine thermoskanne haben und immer ein
glas mit ins auto nehmen ebenfalls ist
dass unser terror pott und da passt
eigentlich soja müsli to go und salat
und reis und so und so weiter und ich
habe da jetzt gerade 400 milliliter
latte macchiato rein gemacht und in
teilen haben sich verziert sind
eigentlich ganz angenehm da passt die
ganze reiserei so jetzt bin ich auch
schon wieder zu hause
wir waren im shop der pakete fertig
gemacht und jetzt muss ich ein käufer
genau wenn man einkaufen sich einkäufe
in die in die schränke einsortieren
und dann muss ich den dreh vorbereiten
denn heute möchte ich unbedingt noch
viel drehen was ist wo doch hier fragt
ihr euch muss kraut also viele kennen
das einige nicht ich persönlich also ich
kannte es bis vor zwei jahren noch gar
nicht habe durch meine schwiegermama
kennengelernt und das sieht ja aus wie
spieler hat so grün und also es sah
nicht ansprechen auch als ich das erste
mal gesehen habe
aber das ist normal das ist einfach so
eine grüne ampel sage ich mal
die aber unglaublich lecker schmeckt mit
muss aber nicht sein fleisch und reis
und dann ist das dann ein ganzes menü
und das schmeckt wirklich sehr lecker
und ist auch sehr gesund und ich hab mir
das jetzt für meine malerei ist es ja
perfekt denn man will sich ja auch
gesund ernähren und jetzt bereitet alles
vor
wo ein paket was könnte sein dass kind
es sein
wir haben uns den lampe bestellt da oben
es nämlich noch keine weißt du was ich
hab dich lieb dich auch so wir sind mit
dem dreh schon fast durch also ich hab
es nur eine stunde kochen lassen
jetzt fehlt nur noch fürs fleisch was
dazu kommen wir sonst mit dazu und
nebenbei komme ich noch hier wird immer
mit reis gegessen
und genau das bereitet jetzt zu dass
film wenn ich ab da überlege ich ein
separates basic video zu machen wie
kommt das für mich besser genau und ich
freue mich in folge hunger es ist 20 23h
noch nicht richtiges gegessen aber daran
kann man sich gewöhnen
der roboter also übermorgen schon seinen
reiz habe ich jetzt richtig gut
ausgespült damit die stärke weg ist und
der nicht klebt und ich mache jetzt hier
diesen typisch türkischen reismehl
diesen leckeren münchen mit schädeln
[Musik]
jetzt wird ganz kurz zu ende gedreht und
dann melde ich nicht wieder so wir sind
jetzt fertig mit dem dreh ist s 21 und
und was hatte ich weiß nicht was noch
ansteht
ich habe mir jetzt vorgenommen dass ich
jetzt immer sofort meine rezepte sofort
nieder schreiber auch die zubereitung
denn unser blog soll ja bald hoffen
nicht online gehen und da für ihn und
einige rezepte und am besten heute schon
ja ja auch das ist kiki in einem
schlager oberteil brille und eine nicht
was es ist
aber ich habe gemerkt dass man auge eine
eine entzündung aufweist aber über hab
ich gemerkt dass wir langsam rot und
brennt eigentlich kontaktlinsen ich hab
ganz schlechte augen
wir sehen wollte ich meine augen show
und will ihn jetzt ein bisschen in der
küche haben noch ganz ganz viel zu tun
besonders für aufräum aber ich habe
gedacht so oben
um 22.40 noch so ein kuchen essen
du warst in meinem blog sehr inaktiv was
soll das nein nicht schon wieder die
haarspangen zu machen
ganz ohne chance aber das ist ja mal so
ohne lästige kann doch eigentlich nur
meinen alltag gezahlt nächste tag werden
heute was herzhaftes während heute
sonntag bei uns gibt's kein wochenende
zu lange nicht mehr
also schon mitfeiern
[Musik]
mit dem blog ihr könnt offiziell sehen
wie ich wir schneiden kommt noch
diskothek kriege sondern braucht haben
ja im laufe nämlich auch nicht videos
schneidet haben sagt gut ein mann so wir
drehen jetzt öfter vom blech also kippe
ob arabische türkische kräfte vom blech
ich finde richtig cool weil man muss
dann auch nicht zehn jahre lang form
aber das original rezept für für
schickedanz sich im hintergrund bestimmt
schreiben jetzt voll viele habt ihr
keine freunde
leute es so im moment arbeiten wir
wirklich von morgens bis nachts und
machen sie auch super gerne also klein
bisschen anstrengend machen super gerne
weil jetzt eben alles auf einmal kommt
die roman reihe der onlineshop und
machen so riesenspaß und meine freunde
haben zum glück verständnis dafür ich
habe sogar leider leider vor zwei tagen
fest gewesen und vor drei aktuell nicht
mehr da wäre ich mit meinen drei mädels
zu kaya yanar gefahren und da musste ich
leider absagen wegen der arbeit aber es
ist nicht stemmen die dass das schützt
ist das allerschönste ist wenn freunde
verständnis haben man kann einem nichts
schöneres schenken als verständnis
übrigens ja bei mir sie in blätter eine
küche immer so aus voller flecken aber
ich hab das rezept vor jahren mal
gemacht und ich mag bei typischen
rezepten ist es damit drin dass sich
immer in tacen messe aber für euch habe
ich das natürlich auch auf der waage
abgemessen
so aber erstmal muss ich mich umziehen
sieht es zwar nicht was ich so
untendrunter an hat ob es eine dienste
so langsam aber fürs gewissen seite ich
bin wieder den team von cleanskin team
und ich habe auf meinen kalender sorgt
und mein papa ich wollte und ich bin
sagte jetzt das video geschnitten und
kopfschmerz alles in ordnung aus
habe ich etwa der trainer gesehen dass
wir so gut geschrieben ist
[Musik]
das ist sehr gut
vor allem die melodie also ich bin zwölf
kilometer nach rheine fahren und suchen
gehen aber das kostet ja nicht wieder
für sein rezept video echt lecker lecker
das ist ein tag vor ramadan heißt für
uns wir können dann bereit
also genießen kaffee trinken in ruhe
ja aber jetzt vorgang dadurch der
vorrang hat aber das wird schon fast
fertig mit dem dreh unser echter
verbrechens gerufen das dauert noch eine
gute halbe stunde
und ich mache jetzt hier schon mal salat
dazu wie ich ein bisschen was klein
geschnippelt und dann zeige ich euch
gleich das leckerste und einfachste
dressing der welt
[Musik]
so und das leckerste dressing geht
folgendermaßen ihr nehmt euch danach ab
version schön viel nicht so viel salz
und so mag eigentlich meiner liebsten
gewürze und bis vor ein paar tagen war
es auch ganz voll davon reichlich
dazugeben und umrühren und wer möchte
kann auch ein bisschen öl dazu geben
es reicht auch schon und das ist das
beste und schnell zu salatdressing er
war das schmeckt so richtig so süßlich
sei also man kann sich ganz beschreiben
granatapfel sirup ist ja eh schon so ne
hausnummer für sich es ist ein bisschen
süß sauer und dieses zu mag es ist er
sich bewusst es ist es ist dann auch
wieder so ein bisschen sauer also
richtig richtig lecker kennt ihr das
wenn die tauben sicher haarspangen kopf
hatten das gefühl es geht ihnen die
kopfhaut rein geht erst mal alle drauf
wohl schön locker lassen so haben sie
ist jetzt zu einem büro fängt schon an
videos wieder weiter zu schneiden genau
das ist dann so wir haben wir dieses
rohmaterial dann da und liegt erstmals
auch eine speicherkarte das muss
irgendwann auch bearbeitet werden und
darum kümmert sich hansa immer und ich
muss jetzt noch schauen dass ich alles
noch mal vernünftig niederschreiben
dadurch werden einen einen blog machen
das ist alle rezepte schriftlich
schriftlich aufgelistet sind und dann
muss ich hier noch aufräumen und das z
vorbereiten endenich stieg auf das noch
einen ofen muss gerechter noch
fotografiert werden und die entsehen
also diese videos sehen müssen noch
gedreht wird und dafür mache ich dann
immer so ein schickes set fertig genau
dann ist es wieder auch fertig bzw es im
kasten fertig ist dann noch nicht jetzt
wird vergessen es gibt bilder sind
nämlich alle schönen kasten
so fragt was machen die beiden jetzt
finde ich immer ein videoclip auch ein
musikvideo klick näheres erfahrt ihr
dann weit so ein update jetzt habt ihr
ganze eineinhalb wann es einen tipp an
dem ich zu mir gehört nach der letzten
szene waren wir nämlich noch die ganze
nacht im shop bis fast bis zum sommer
und dann haben wir gegessen und den
ersten fastentag den haben wir
überstanden also ich fande ich finde
dass der erste mal schwierig ist man so
schlapp hat kopfschmerzen ist doch ganz
normal
ihr könnt dann musste ich erst mal an
die an die umstände an die umstellung
gewöhnen man sieht mich im spiegel
na ja auf jeden fall habe wollte ich
euch mal kurz ein kurzes update geben
und den block i doch so langsam beenden
da ist bestimmt auch schon ziemlich
langsam schneidet den ganzen tag schon
das video für morgen das ist schlicht
hefter vom blech das wird dann online
sein winter blog online ist also ihr
werdet es schon gesehen haben und ihr
werdet auch schon ein bäumchen nach oben
gegeben haben und einen kommentar da
gelassen
die laterne hat serie genauso sterben ja
schöne datenrettungs zwei bis zu vier
haben ich weiß gar nicht das ist ja also
lässt er ganz viel daran fehler gemacht
da muss es wieder okay haben sie noch
mal fleißig weiter näher und ich
berichte mal was sonst noch so abging
und falls ihr euch wundert 90 an habe
leute es gibt nichts schöneres im
ramadan einfach eine abba anziehen und
runter pyjama oder hauptsache bequem
denn am ramadan ist doch ganz normal
dass ich mit aber ja kaum laufen jetzt
endlich vom tag kaufmann war nämlich
heute hier bzw
das team von juden das fototeam und es
hat so viel spaß gemacht wir haben für
für das kaufland ja für die kauf und
kooperation fotos gemacht sehr
professionelle fotos sind richtig spaß
gemacht und ich bin schon flash
produktes ergebnis was ich vorbereitet
habe für das shooting das zeige ich euch
jetzt mal einmal habe ich diesen
mandarinen käsekuchen vorbereitet so die
konnte ich am ende auch noch verteilen
da war es nämlich schon alles im kasten
dann hatten wir hier noch cookies und
gugelhupf und hier habe ich noch eine
himbeer mascarpone torte das problem ist
ich habe dem zucker vergessen als ich
das zubereitet haben die antrag
vorzubereiten und die tupfer sind hier
auch ein bisschen schief weil ich
währenddessen immer wieder in die kamera
gucken musste aber ja total ärgerlich
mit dem zucker aber vielleicht schmeckt
ja doch weil es ist ja seine drin und
hin werden ich nehme ihn gleich einfach
mal mit wenn ich den schwiegereltern mal
gucken wie das schmeckt dann kann man
einfach mal probieren und schauen und
was ich noch zubereitet hatte so als
reserve des kabels aber nicht zum
einsatz aber nicht schlimm das ist ein
mürbeteig und hier habe ich eine
seine frisch käsecreme schmeckt richtig
schön frisch hier haben wir noch ganz
viele erdbeeren und ich werde jetzt
einfach die erdbeeren noch auf die tat
legen vielleicht noch so ein bus mit
engagement schauen und dann werde ich
den auch mitnehmen so jetzt würde ich
den blog hier ganz einfach beenden und
ich habe auf jeden fall vor regelmäßiger
zu bloggen
es macht einfach richtig viel spaß euch
mitzunehmen das macht mir richtig spaß
ich will nämlich auch mal dass ihr seht
wie sie den alltag abläuft viele sehen
das ja auch schon auf instagram 15
sekunden ausschnitte und das ist nur ein
bruchteil von dem was passiert in einem
tag deshalb nehme ich euch jetzt öfter
machen wird schreibt mir doch gerne in
die kommentare was diese blog haltet
eure meinungen zu verschiedenen themen
die wir jetzt hier aufgegriffen haben
und hinterlassen wir gerne einen leben
kommentar darüber freut mich immer total
und dann würde ich mal sagen moment die
verabschiedung muss ich mit hansa machen
ich bin jetzt wird die musik hat
schneien dann das einschalten kann so
denken wie es einschalten und bis zum
nächsten
[Musik]